(funky music)
- You said you're a bartender.
Have you hooked up with a customer before?
- I have.
(upbeat music)
- So how old was everybody
when they had sex
for the first time?
I'll start. It was 18 for me.
From what I understand pretty late.
- I was 17.
- I think it was like 14, 15? Yeah.
- I was 15.
- I was 18.
Because I came out of the closet at 18
so that's when I was like,
"Okay, now I'm gonna see the world."
So I feel like right now I'm in my peak.
(laughter)
- Man, let's go, Art.
- Like when you getting on your own,
you know what I'm saying?
You spreading your wings.
You trying to explore.
- In my undergraduate years,
since I went away for university,
I felt like I could
probably explore my wing...
Or what'd you say? Expand my wings?
- Yeah, spread your wings.
- Spread your wings.
- Yeah, spread my wings.
And just explore like what
else is out there as well.
- It was a big like awakening for me
because I was a very late bloomer.
Like I didn't hit puberty
until very late in high school.
I didn't even kiss a girl
until I got into college.
But then I made up a
lot of ground quickly.
I was gonna ask about professions.
Like you said you're a bartender,
I would imagine you meet a
whole lot of people bartending.
- Yeah.
- Have you hooked up
with a customer before?
- I have.
- Oh my God.
- I hooked up with a customer before.
I try not to though because
some of them are like regulars.
- It can get messy for sure.
- You're like, "I don't know
if I want to see my ex hook up
come into work every day."
I don't know about that.
- What was everybody's
longest relationship?
Mine was like two and a bit
years, and I'm single right now.
- Okay.
- My longest relationship was three years
and currently I'm not single.
- For me, longest relationship 12 years.
And I am not single now.
- I don't think I ever officially had one.
Forever single.
(laughter)
- My longest relationship was eight years
and I am currently single.
In my community, like it's very common
to have open relationships
and stuff like that.
Or even like throuples
I just know for me, I'm
a very jealous person,
so if it ever got serious
I'd have to be like,
"Okay, you need to rein
this in a little bit."
I'm gay so in the gay community,
or in any of the queer community,
we tend to have a little bit more
of an open mind when it comes to sex
just because we grow up
being told that everything
that we do is wrong.
- Like couple months ago, I wasn't like...
I was the same as you as well, Ariana.
I was like, "I don't
wanna like be with anyone.
I wanna be single."
Because I like my independence,
I'm a very independent person as well.
But then like I met
someone and I was like,
"Wait, this person's
actually really cool."
- And growing up, I was
raised very Catholic
which I got mixed messages
because my one parent
was kind of religious,
the other one didn't really participate.
- For me, in terms of like
a traditional relationship,
I do believe in that kind of concept.
In terms of right now,
I'm purposely single.
Because right now the closest
thing I have to a relationship
is just that I've been hooking up
with the same person
long term, but it's not-
- Exclusive?
- Thank you.
But I know when I get married I want that
to be like just me and them and that's it.
(upbeat music)
- I hope nobody nobody's
gonna get offended
when we're ranking people.
- No, nothings personal.
It's gonna be interesting.
Okay. I think you're five.
- Okay.
I think you come from a very
conservative background.
He seems like a more conservative mindset
in that point of view when he talks
about relationships and marriage.
And so that's when I viewed him
as someone who would
have a lower body count.
I think you have four, I think.
Okay.
- I like four.
- Yeah. Four. Okay, cool. Cool, cool.
I'm glad we agree.
(laughter)
And I think I'm in the middle.
I think I'm three.
Anwen, I think you're two.
Yeah. I think that would make sense.
And especially compared to
Chris, I think you're one.
- Anwen, I think you're five.
- All right.
- Partially because
you're still very young
and you did say you have a partner
that you've been regularly seeing.
I think I would have you at four.
I don't really have any great reasons.
You, Chris, at three.
I would put myself at
two and maybe you at one.
- Okay.
- Cool.
- I'm gonna put you at five.
- Okay.
- Yeah. Just because
you're in a relationship.
- That's true.
- Yeah. So I just feel...
And you're still young
so I'm like, I don't
know how long you've been
in a relationship but
I feel like that could
have cut some time off
of you experimenting.
Especially if you're in a monogamous.
Actually, I'm gonna keep like this.
So four for you as well.
- Go right down the line.
- Yeah, right down the line.
- Just because you're in a relationship
and I know you said you
were a late bloomer,
so I'm like, there might
have been some time
where you just like experimented a lot.
You're still young, but you
say you started young as well.
Obviously you're number one because-
(laughter)
... you're like, "I've never
been in a relationship."
I'm like, "Okay, well that's number one."
- Yes.
- That's number one.
- I thought based off how
everybody was ranking me,
I was thinking to myself,
"Maybe I am number one."
- You're the problem. I
don't know where to put you.
- I'm the problem.
- You're the problem.
- That's not the first
time I've been told that,
unfortunately.
- You said your longest
relationship is 12 years?
- Mm-hmm.
- I think you're five because
of the 12 year relationship.
He didn't have a lot of other time
where he wasn't monogamous.
I think you're four because
we're around the same age.
Both young.
I think you're three
because I don't think you're two or one.
I'm two I think.
(laughter)
- Now I know I messed up for sure.
You put yourself at two then
you're definitely not five.
- Five. I'm going to go you.
- Cool. Me.
- You. I'm actually gonna
put you at like four.
I'm putting you at three.
You let your wings loose.
And you're a bartender as well too
so I can see how you can
get some numbers there.
I'm putting myself at two.
I'm putting you at one.
You put yourself at two so I'm like,
"Yeah, you might got me beat."
- [Instructor] So I
was gonna have you guys
rearrange yourselves.
But the averages that you
guys came out to actually
keeps you in the same exact order.
- We went kind of down the line?
That was so funny.
- Yeah. There's no way this is right.
(mischievous music)
(upbeat music)
- [Instructor] In spot number five
with the least we have Sophia at 13.
Number four, we have Art with 22.
Number three, we have Chris with 24.
Which is actually a tie
with Anwen who is also 24.
And spot number one, we have Oki at 50.
- Cha-ching.
(upbeat music)
- But, I've added a couple
since the last time I interviewed.
So I'm actually, I'd be
second right now actually.
(laughter)
I was counting on the car ride here.
- And that makes me
closer to correct, my man.
Let's go.
- [Instructor] You have
to give us a number
to put above your head, so let us know.
- Oh, 27.
I feel like I come off
as kind of innocent.
So I feel like that's what
people usually perceive me as.
I'm single, I'm a bartender and all that.
I'm just trying to have fun right now.
So like I know at any given time
like from week to week,
it's gonna keep increasing.
So that's when it's like, yeah.
- Art, I'm in a monogamous relationship
and it's not changing anytime soon.
You're gonna be number
one in no time, I promise.
I don't think anybody
had me as high as three.
It was just that period before
that 12 year relationship
when I was in my early and mid-twenties,
I had a really good time.
- If everybody's having more sex
then we're all gonna have better sex.
- Yes. Practice does make perfect.